hello everyone I'm sorry I'm Dan and
today we're going to talk about payday 2
crimewave edition which Dan and I got
hands on with recently we did this is a
rerelease of payday 2 with them pretty
much all of its DLC for the Xbox one and
ps4 that's right and in addition to that
they've also bumped up the textures made
it look nicer and it's in 1080p that's
right yeah
and I think depending on what system you
buy it on you get to a system exclusive
mask as well yes that is correct
so the ps3 and xbox 360 editions to have
some DLC but they actually don't have
access to all of them which is what the
crimewave Edition includes so what we're
looking at here we've gone straight into
the diamond heist which is exclusive to
the PC ps4 and Xbox one versions and
this pre-planning mode actually sorry
this pre-planning mode itself came with
a DLC called the big big bank heist and
it enables you to go into this screen
before you actually go on the heist with
your friends or with your crew or maybe
random so this is a map overview of the
level you're about to go into yeah and
you can actually draw on this as well I
play on the PC so I know from experience
that you can draw on this and see like
your crew members can see what you're
drawing so if you want to kinda like
Rainbow six you can draw a path for
people you want to go go here and go
left and yeah pretty much
and it's really useful for pre-planning
when you want to be like okay there you
come in through this side and everyone
else comes through this side in addition
to drawing you actually can place down
extra I guess little points
to help you along with the mission so as
you can see here we're mousing over
extra camera access more drop-off points
for like bags and ammo and med kits and
such and those things cost money and
favors which is a way of limiting the
amount of assets you can actually drop
on the map right and money is what you
actually own by doing the heists that's
right so here we've gone straight into
the screen and tried to go in through
the front door I think just shot the
lockout or
you attempted to shoot the lock out
there and I think you've just raised the
alarm pretty straight away did not
usually how I skated to go well you know
I figured that this was my first time
playing the PSR there's the Xbox one
version I was like you know what let's
just right in and go loud
I don't usually heist this way oh I
believe you I believe it I played a lot
of payday on PC so I'm well aware of how
the game works how did you find the
controls on console it was actually not
too bad I mean there's not a lot of
stuff that you used to do but yeah
accidentally shot a civilian ah sorry
about that CB having a bad day it was
one day away from retire but it's
actually not too bad I mean that it's
the standard FPS like you know move
around left stick press into crouch and
shoot with your triggers and such
picking locks and interacting with
objects is done by the Bopper triggers
on the Xbox one version and it's worth
pointing out that like interacting with
most things takes a fair amount of time
and the game is kind of designed like
that so you have one person interacting
with something the Resta covering them
and it's all designed to kind of
increase tension you know as waves of
cops swarming in or times the time is
ticking down yeah that's right and I
actually thought that the HUD could have
done with a bit of improvement as you
can see here in this version it looks
exactly the same as it does on the PC
version now the hard wouldn't be so much
of a problem if you're playing up
against the computer screen because you
can see all the numbers and what
everyone's got really easily but I
imagine if you're playing on a big TV
and you're sitting back far further away
from it it might be hard to see whatever
I was actually carrying so I think it
would have been better if they use maybe
like bigger icons or made it more
obvious like colored ones with the
numbers like of what everyone's actually
carrying into your highest and made more
obvious so that would have been nice to
see them change this version of the game
so with this dlc high specifically i
mean what they tried to do with the dlc
which you probably might other Havoc's
played on console is create much larger
levels with more complex objectives and
kind of more stages to each heist as
well so talk about what you're actually
going through at the moment here and
what were you trying to accomplish okay
so this one the big goal at the end of
this level is to steal the diamond and
you got to go through all sorts of well
I guess if you didn't alert the police
at this point it would have been a lot
easier but here we're trying to break
through all these time blocks to get
through so the first part we did did
just earlier was we had to hack into the
system to get past that point and now
we're doing the time locks and as you
can see that the police try to stop you
along each way and these are kind of
like points where they try to slow the
game down or make it longer because you
have to wait for the the lock to finish
or wait for the you know the computer to
finish hacking so we've cut to a new
mission now and this is the hotline
miami dlc mission sums a mission
inspired by hotline miami obviously you
can fight the guys in the 70s white
suits and yeah and you can get the masks
as well with a better available hotline
miami and this one's also exclusive to
this version as well as PC version and I
thought this was actually a really fun
one because we did a lot of it was it's
a really open level you do a lot of
running back and forth and you set a lot
of things on fire which is really fun or
if on definitely a loud mission as well
and for this one I actually equipped
specific dlc specific punching gloves
which you will see in the moment
hopefully which i thought was really
funny because here as you can see i'm
holding just normal like yeah i'm
wearing normal blue plastic gloves so
what do you think this is worth
repurchase or a first-time purchase for
people who may not to play the PC
version if if you are like coming
straight up not having played play-doh
before then I think yes definitely if
you're coming at it from even 360 or the
ps3 versions I think all the DLC is has
a lot of content that's worth checking
out
cool right a day to crime wave edition
you